oh man this is what happened
[Music]
good morning we are on the road because
we are actually headed to Sequoia
National Park we got this really cool
like RV camper thing for tonight so it's
like a really quick two-day one-night
kind of trip unfortunately Isaac
couldn't join us because he has school
tomorrow but Luca's here and he's
sleeping right now I've never been to a
surprise National Park so I'm super
excited to see like giant trees all
right so we have now Stockton I'm not
able to ride actually but we stopped out
of Starbucks Luke over here was causing
a lot of ruckus he was crying a lot
wanting to get out I was feeding him by
leaning over into the car seat and
whipping my milk into his mouth and that
wasn't enough he was like no I need to
stretch my legs and now he's happy now
he's out of his car seat you happy now
baby
[Music]
that's his favorite Mickey lucarino
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
little Explorer I need some nice fresh
air during the road trip get some
sunshine some vitamin D good for
regulating or hormones I think vitamin D
makes you happy or something that's what
I learned from the pandemic
because everyone stayed in cyberville
smells so good
Little League
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we decided to stop to get gas before we
get too far into the National Park area
where it's just like trees and land and
there's no civilization like our Airbnb
guy was saying there's not like a food
place within five miles of the Airbnb so
this is kind of like the last bit of
civilization before we get in that area
and now we're getting some last minute
Mexican food and then we're gonna head
up the mountain he's like we're on the
schedule the Sun is setting why did you
guys choose to do a sit-down Place
rather than going through
[Music]
[Music]
you want some
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
all right
foreign
yes so I finally got a new Mexican
blanket from an authentic Mexican man
literally on her way up here you
purchased a blanket we also found our
little a bear yeah we found a little
Cookie Monster bear Cookie Monster what
do you think we're gonna sleep here
tonight Buffy look can't wait to see
what the view looks like it's during the
day I know we missed our window
supposed to get here before the sun went
down it was enjoy the view or Mexican
food
look at that
so cute and fluffy you're so fluffy
[Music]
what do you think
stay tonight
[Music]
all right
look at how awesome this looks and we
brought sandwich supplies
you put the baby to sleep in the car
seat we're gonna move into the bed later
but
like okay sleeping we can make dinner
you probably enjoy our Airbnb yeah
so get him down morning dance hi baby
it you're happy that's your happy dance
how'd you sleep last night cutie
how did you
did you scrape but mommy and daddy
weren't so great you were literally like
up against the edges and he was in the
middle like stretched across
the thing sleeping this way yeah at home
you sleep in your own crib and you sleep
11 hours but here he slept for five
hours woke up to eat and then only
another three hours
tell me what you're doing right now yeah
I think it's because he's teething he
could feel his teeth in the top he has
three teeth coming up on the top
he's like three three teeth
so side note this is the blanket that we
bought off the side of the road and I
forgot to mention too that I literally
pulled this off of the guy's van because
this was the last the last design like
the last Rose one that he had so I'm
like you know what we're taking it you
bled right in baby um
let's get ready and go see some big
trees
hi baby so I have to drive two hours two
more hours to see the trees two hours to
the National Forest I didn't I didn't
think this place was that far away from
the national forest it's making
breakfast
you already had breakfast oh my gosh
check that there
first time trying pear check out my
culinary creation that looks awesome I'm
putting cubed up pear so I'm saving the
sliced ones for Luca even though he's
not gonna eat this much
but
I like your your spoon yeah your pear
spoon
it's okay you look beautiful this is Bed
Head here yes we all have your hair we
all got bad hair look at this though
this is our view out the door it's so
quiet out here and then we have a
watchdog it comes with the uh Airbnb
property ready to eat yeah you gotta eat
and head out okay all right we are
officially off to Hoya National Park
yeah and we're gonna see the world's
largest tree the largest living organism
on the entire planet and there is no
there's like little notice after night
here so I mapped it before we head out
and hopefully we get there whoa
[Music]
this is crazy wow these trees are so
straight they're like telephone poles I
don't blame you for hugging your
telephone pole when you're a kid and all
these Nature's telephone poles
[Music]
sorry I'm trying to drive it steady and
less bumpy as possible to love this I'm
so bummed he's missing out I'm scared
that our tires are gonna pop or
something
or more we're gonna get more stuff
okay
do you want to say what's happening all
right so trying to get past this turn
here and we just keep getting stuck it's
a combination of snow and it being very
very muddy we have no Chains It's not a
four-wheel vehicle either but yeah this
is the turn
for trying to get around once we get
here this is very loose how far does it
go come on I think we can even make this
trip if it keeps going on like this yeah
it's a difficult one Ford actually
sponsored tips IG and so they give us a
free car to drive around and then we
decided to take it up to Sequoia and I
think this might be the end of the road
so the trick now is to try and turn the
car around oh it's really annoying I
didn't think about the possibility of
snow I bought some of those things for
your tires for snow years ago just to
have like just in case if I ever need
them yep and the moment we do anything
did I bring them no we did not I didn't
think about it either because so
it went out to Idlewild
it was no it was like little patches
here yeah and for some reason in my mind
I'm like I'll just be like Idlewild just
I can't even bigger trees
well let's try to turn around shall we
oh
[Music]
my God
[Music]
this is what happened
we got further in
dang it's the other Tire
oh man
what we're trying to do now
is clear the ice Tiff's the only one
that has gloves because I didn't bring
gloves tis always ready I'm the least
prepared
true
underneath
all right so we've been stuck here for
more than an hour now and Casey
successfully got us out of that but now
we're stuck there
gravity's working against us what do you
think Luca see daddy's getting us out
he's working hard well I just gave him
the hardest ever in Luca's entire life
the most difficult diaper change ever he
just kept turning and twisting and I'm
like trying to do in the back seat the
fact that the car is like at an incline
the gravity was working against me to
give him a diaper change too you did not
make it easy on your mama
you did not make it easy no
[Music]
oh oh stop oh my God that's scary
because there's like a drop right behind
you
wait at this point you could turn
forward okay it's fine
[Music]
yay Daddy got us out
good job celebration
all right we're gonna keep the car
facing this way we'll just go down
backwards until we um there's a dryer
less icy area stress is off my mind now
because we're not stuck I'm gonna go
walk around for a little bit do you have
a car here for now actually yeah because
I just put him in the carrier so I'm
like I kind of don't want to take them
off
okay all right now we get to go explore
you're nice and bundled up in your
little blueberries look at that well
Luca we won't see the world's largest
tree this trip but you know what that
means we will just have to come back
with your big brother foreign
a big tree not the biggest tree
apparently but that's a big tree
[Music]
look at this view behind you look at
that you're like a Mongolian baby
how about the next time we come we come
prepared to go camping and we schedule
it when Isaac can come because I know he
would love this yes absolutely come back
can I come back and show you big brother
these big trees
[Music]
his face is so cute that was cute
wow look at this tree
we should hug it
[Applause]
oh it's like wet inside
oh yeah it's probably sticky
[Music]
I can't really hug a tree with a child
on my chest you're hugging a tree and
Luca oh it's like super crispy it's been
burned it needs more love Yeah on that
side specifically all right so we're
back in the car we're moving forward
what you missed that we didn't Vlog is
once we got back to the car after
exploring and walking around and
everything Casey was driving backwards
while I was walking ahead with Luca
because he had fallen asleep on the
carrier so we walked how long do you
think that was about like 20 minutes 20
it felt like an hour to me oh my God I
was exhausted trying to walk on the snow
and like not slip and making sure to
keep Luca sleeping and all that but
anyway So eventually we got to a point
where there was no snow on the floor and
no mud so Casey was able to turn around
and now we're facing the correct way of
driving he's not driving in Reverse but
yeah that was like a little mini
Adventure there that we didn't Vlog
because I was just so focused on like
don't slip keep walking even though
you're tired and then Casey's just so
focused on like don't uh drive off a
cliff I'm really surprised that we got
all the way up here he's going back down
I'm like man any of these spots we could
have just gotten stuck that's true
right here
oh my goodness that looks scary
I just literally feels like the Indiana
Jones ride yeah yeah how do we get up
that thing I don't know there's a cow
that just crossed the street
that's crazy it's bigger than her car
look how polite the cow is it's like
walking
do you need a boat
he's like trying to hurry up too like
sorry you're holding on traffic I'm
sorry
well I think it's a girl right is it a
girl I see Udders underneath I don't
think there's boy cows no boy colors are
both bowls yeah yeah okay we're gonna
pass you
here in the very back
so cute
it's hurting the cows now
we're Shepherds oh there we go
[Music]
bye cows
[Music]